selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
la troisième ris et son époux ont
regagné leur cabine du msc preciosa aux
environs de minuit heure à laquelle le
paquebot naviguer avant-hier dans cette
zone au niveau de la guadeloupe est
longé les côtes de la dominique cap sur
la martinique
ce n'est qu'à se réveille que l'on
constate la disparition de son épouse il
informe rapidement le commandant de bord
en l arrivée à fort-de-france
l'alerté donnée la police nationale
engage alors les premières
investigations le cross tiguan prend le
relais nous avons immédiatement engagé
une opération de recherche en mer
en partant de la trajectoire du navire
entre minuit et l'arrivée à fort de
france
ce qui nous a permis dans un premier
temps de faire une opération de
recherches avec l'hélicoptère de la
gendarmerie nationale qui investit les
la baie de fort-de-france et le proche
côtier au niveau de la côte sous le vent
de la martinique et dans un deuxième
temps un aéronef de la marine nationale
a pu être engagé décollé en milieu de
journée pour investiguer la zone qui
était plus hauturières ce matin prenant
en compte plusieurs paramètres
le conseil met un terme recherche c'est
tenir landaise âgé de 69 ans aujourd'hui
à compte tenu des éléments dont nous
disposons par rapport aux recherches
quand elle fait à bord c'est que la
personne ne disposait pas d'équipements
de sécurité pas de gilet pas des dallas
potabilité que si elle est tombée du
navire depuis sa cabine a fait une chute
de 30 mètres et est donc tous ces
éléments nous avons amené effectivement
a confirmé qu'il a plus d'espoir
raisonnable de retrouver la personne
vivante aujourd'hui en milieu de journée
et c'est pour ça que les recherches par
moyens dirigés sont sont arrêtés
néanmoins le koçak diffuse des
informations à tous les navires de
commerce ou autres embarcations
naviguant dans la zone
pour tout contact composé le cross aux
[Applaudissements]